make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing on with our
discussions on venom this is actually
kind of cool and here's okay here's the
reason why I've intimate school when it
comes to war of the realms because when
it comes to this whole thing you have
the Venom symbiote and then you have
Eddie Brock and historically they've
always been one in the same right it's
only really been in like recent years
within the last 10 years or so maybe a
little bit longer but you've seen like
some development with the simian itself
right like before was just a thing
that's there in Eddie Brock was a bad
guy here's the deal guys like I was
never the biggest fan of venom and I
don't know if it's Donnie Cates writing
or what I mean this is written by : Bunn
but I know if it's Donnie Cates writing
or whatever the case is but like venom
is awesome now and maybe it was just he
was always underrated by me and I just
never forgave him you know never gave
him enough credit but I feel like venom
has gotten a lot more interesting a lot
better in the last couple years let me
know what you guys think I'm kind of
curious what you guys think about the
venom like the whole venom concept the
stories and all that kind of good stuff
but uh in really this kind of picks up
with 13 and it runs up to runs up to 15
so really this almost seems to pick up
like as soon as as soon as 12 ended we
immediately went to war of realms again
with the nature of comics we don't
really get an indication of how much
time passes from one event to the next
it's just a series of sequential events
but for the most part we can likely
assume that like maybe a couple days at
most of have passed here but regardless
of the circumstance I would say it's
almost immediate and the reason why was
because if in the last of the the story
out before this Eddie basically learned
that he had a son named Dylan right like
it was literally his biological son that
Eddie's father had been raising as his
own and so Dylan doesn't know that
Eddie's his actual father the result is
that when Eddie essentially took him
away from what was abuse in abusive
situation or at least an abusive dad
this turned into Eddie kind of taking
the son for his own and then trying to
find something to do with him which
immediately goes into war of realms so
again it seems to happen almost
immediately there's no real time that
passes here then this is one of the
things that I think a lot of people who
were fans of Eddie Brock will really get
their due because Eddie's always kind of
been a guy where it's like okay he's
pretty awesome in and of its in himself
but like he was always kind of a mixed
bag right letting the guys capable he
can do a lot of things but at the same
time there was already sort of sort of
this indicator that like Eddie seems
kind of helpless that a symbian and
that's changed over the years right and
like in this moment when the forces of
malakut show up and there's some
innocents who are being threatened Eddie
steps out absolute the symbian and says
like we're gonna fix this anyway like
I'm gonna face off against all these
guys anyway and do the best that I can
and for the most part he actually holds
his own now of course again
Eddie's got a lot of experience here
he's not really coming to this with no
real idea of what he's doing but it's a
moment for like people who are fans of
Eddie to kind of look at this and say
yeah man like Eddie's not helpless he
can do stuff like by himself without the
Venom symbiote right so it's kind of
like Flash Thompson getting his own
moment after the Venom symbiote at
Eddie's getting his as well now of
course once they end up getting to the
safe house of Rex Strickland who of
course at one point was I who had like
all these arms and armament almost kind
of have functional according to like
Nick Fury right like where Nick Fury
always had these underground bunkers and
always had a safe space but one of the
war witches shows up and greets Eddie
Brock now the war which is have been
very ambiguous up to this point lighten
like the only thing we really knew about
them is that they were one of the
sources of power that Malekith was using
in his war of realms and even before
that like launching this major campaign
right and that's one of the things to
keep in mind when it comes to Marvel
Comics one of the things to keep in mind
at least for the new guys anyway is
there are a lot of people out there who
can use various forms of magic right I
mean we've seen that manifest in a
variety of different ways when we look
to add Jeff Lemire stano's run we had
the coven of witches in the god Corey
Riley that gets happened to magic you've
got Agatha Harkness who's a legitimate
witch you've got Doctor Strange who
borrows the powers of other people
you've got all kinds of individuals out
there who can use all forms of magic and
that's just in light like beasts on
earth but when Eddie Paul's had gone
literally like she melts it in his hand
and then in turn presents it with what's
called the dream stone now unlike a lot
of things that we've seen over the
course of the Asgardian mythos right
like my things like the casket of
ancient winters which basically
unleashes like the near infinite cold of
like Jotunheim things like that the
dream stone is essentially a wholly new
creation by by Cullen Bunn now the funny
thing about this and the way this will
end is that it kind of gives us a little
bit of a teaser of like what to expect
later on but the dream stone comes with
this witch who basically says hey look I
can give you what it is that you want I
can give you the kind of weapons you
need in order to essentially win and
it's sort of funny because the way she
presents it is that the dream stone
bends to the whim of its will of its of
its user right like Binns to its will
and gives a user whatever it wants but
in this instance like she presents the
stone to Eddie Brock and then it's her
and Eddie Brock accepts it now the
motivation behind accepting this it
really kind of comes in a couple
different ways the first is that it kind
of appears that Eddie either takes it
because he needs to feel powerful that's
one of the things that kind of came with
a venom Simmi Riley the Venom symbiote
gave Eddie of how her he didn't already
have the the I guess you know I kind of
give him the ability to really challenge
spider-man in his days of anger
following that the
Simmi was actually a means for
redemption for Eddie Brock it was a
means for him to kind of a tone and make
up for the things that he'd done in the
past he considered to be bad basically
villainous acts uh the other half of
this is that it could be that Eddie just
wants to be a good guy he wants to do
good deeds and by virtue of wanting to
do good deeds he takes the stream stone
Simbi it on but the cool thing is that
this basically imbues him with seemingly
all the powers of the venom simian but
it seems to be more powerful than normal
he basically like cuts off the arms of
one of the war witches now one of the
things to bear in mind here is that
because this is a war which that does
hail from the realm of sparta ha in the
realm of Malekith then what this seems
to indicate is that she's on par with
Malekith not not necessarily in terms of
magic but in terms of like strength
durability things like that Eddie kind
of going out with this symbian and
basically attacking almost everything he
finds the caveat comes into play when he
begins to lose himself and that's one of
the funny things because he says you
know that that whenever he had the venom
Samiha he always heard Venom's voice in
his head right he always heard the
symbionts voice kind of resonating in
his mind in the early days it was we got
to take out spider-man and the more
recent days it's Eddie we can do good
things but he doesn't hear any other
voice in here other than his own and
what what is basically doing is it's
feeding on his rage and that's when we
game when he begins to sort of realize
what's actually going on here that
essentially what's been taking place is
that when he gets this this dream stone
symbiote at any bonds to it that feeds
on his rage and then in doing so it
manifests every ounce of anger he has in
the physical form of his symbiote
meaning the angrier he is this stronger
he gets
now I love ders if that's absolute that
kana seems to be the case but like
literally he's withstanding a full
onslaught from like giants and like
trolls and like the forces of Malekith
and the forces of cinder he's become a
one-man army and it's kind of a cool
little thing because in response to this
with with basically venom turning
against the war which cutting off her
arm in the process she ends up turning
to a foe a guy by the name of Jack
O'Lantern now there have been a
multitude of people who have played the
mantle of Jack O'Lantern and in fact
it's kind of funny because of the way
the Jack O'Lantern functions people
sometimes confuse him with with the
Green Goblin and I know other people who
are really familiar with comics is kind
of like how though it's like infusing
Iron Man with Captain America that's
true but you got to think about it from
the perspective of like non coming book
readers you got guys who are basically
throwing these small little portable
bombs of people so it's very easy to
kind of get those teams those those two
things confused but in the history of
Marvel really there have been like two
major versions or at least I would say
two supremely popular versions of Jack
O'Lantern the first was Jason Masonville
who was basically the original
and then then like Stephen Levin's now
Stephen Elevens brother eventually
became jack-o'-lantern I mean the
characters got a lengthy history he's
not brand new
right like Machine Man was the first
appearance of jack-o'-lantern who's like
18 or 19 back in like 1981 or something
along those lines regardless of the
scenario the various iterations of these
characters have kind of followed a
common theme in the sense of like a
Halloween based theme but
jack-o'-lantern is nothing to scoff at
right like he's not a villain to like
poke fun at and make fun of in some ways
he's pretty dangerous now for spider-man
he's used to him he's not much of a
threat offer Eddie Brock he's pretty
easy to take out but at the end of the
day jack-o'-lantern can still be pretty
dangerous the issue is that this is a
new version of Jack now it depends on
what they end up doing with him for the
most part he has usually been treated as
a throwaway villain really ever since
Steven Levinson kind of went away he's
really just kind of been a villain who
was there and that was basically it but
it is kind of cool here because what is
up happening is that like in response to
the powers of jack-o'-lantern I guess
the abilities of jack-o'-lantern
throwing these you know crazy bombs and
so on and so forth suddenly Eddie Brock
ends up down a daunting this sort of
like rock based suit and so it's really
really cool because the suit modifies
itself more so than the venom Samiha
that we've seen do before on its own we
see this suit modify itself according to
Eddie now remember it's the dream stone
that's basically doing it all and that's
why it's kind of a cool theme because
then you have this great big huge
knock-down drag-out fight between like
Eddie and jack-o'-lantern now it's not
the greatest fight in the history of the
world jack-o'-lantern riding like this
giant flaming Beast and then like
descending down on Eddie that's pretty
badass that's pretty cool if I'm being
honest with you guys but the fight ends
relatively fast but one of the things to
bear in mind here is again Eddie's not
truly himself right I mean
jack-o'-lantern possessing all these
things comes my way the dream stone
under normal circumstances he would
never be able to do these things but
because the war which gave him a dream
stone in addition to Eddie having one it
amplifies and changes the abilities of
jack-o'-lantern now if I'm a betting man
this is gonna continue on and we're
gonna see this version of Jack with
these kind of powers later on but at the
moment it's kind of a cool little
skirmish and if Jack O'Lantern has ever
been this cool in the history of Marvel
Comics I would have cared a lot more
about it but it's it's crazy little
things right because one of the things
that seems to indicate is like the
ability to basically reconstitute one's
self right because in in this fight that
happens Eddie Brock actually cuts Jack
in half and then Jack O'Lantern reforms
himself and comes back so it seems to be
the indication that like he can you can
basically sort of reconstitute yourself
well then in turn this is
thrown out the window and we end up
finding out that was basically like a
drone like a fake version of Jack and
like the actual Jack finally shows up
and ends up fighting against Eddie but
again like the fight ends pretty quickly
and the reason why ends up turning out
because of the fact that this is not
really an experienced Jack O'Lantern
this is a guy who just stumbled across
the stuff right the guy who just kind of
came across the stuff of one of the old
jack-o'-lanterns and then donned the
uniform and then took off right so it
was like if a random guy came across
like this shield of Captain America and
the costume put it on and decided to go
be Captain America
what do you probably get the hell beat
out of him because he's not Captain
America he doesn't have the Super
Soldier Serum and so he would just get
absolutely crushed and then probably
laughed at probably kind of made fun of
and picked at and so on but in the
middle of all this
Eddie begins to kind of regain himself
right this is one of the important
things because Eddie has to sort of make
a choice in the middle of this whole
conflict there's some ants some some
innocents that are caught in the
crossfire and in addition to those
innocents there are some forces of of
Muspelheim the forces of cinder who
basically descend here with the
intention of killing them and so Eddie
has to make the choice either he faces
off against Jack O'Lantern and tries to
stop him or he saves these innocents and
in this moment of redemption Eddie goes
after and saves the innocents and this
is kind of : buns way of saying hey look
yeah Eddie's still a good guy and that's
one of the many complaints that a lot of
people were really worried about when it
came to Eddie right like I mean I love
the idea of Eddie you need to send me it
back a lot of people wanted Flash
Thompson to get it back but I was like
no no no no I'm old school get it back
to Eddie and he's got to have it and I
don't think me and the Flash Thompson
guys will ever see eye to eye when it
comes to who should be the proper host
of the venom Sevilla which is fun
because I love getting all those those
debates with you guys right because like
those are guys who omit me at
conventions we've had that conversation
like which venom is the best venom
definitely Eddie Brock you're crazy it's
definitely Flash Thompson it's it's it's
fun to go back and forth with those
discussions but one of the things that
people were concerned about is that if
Eddie got the venom Soviet back any
would go back to being a villain that's
not the case Eddie is if anything an
antihero
but I would say probably more like to
being a straight-up hero now right I
mean literally putting himself in harm's
way and then going and saving innocents
as opposed to going and stopping the
villain that's really something that I
hear oh we do is something spider-man
would do Captain America Thor but again
like he's really kind of a tried and
true hero and that's the important thing
is because when he sits down and says
like I realize like I remember why I'm
doing all this because I'm trying to
make sure that Dylan is safe I'm trying
to get him out of harm's way I'm trying
to be a good guy what he ends up doing
is seemingly unlocking the full
potential of the symbiote I'm sorry of
this dream stone
and using the entirety and the entirety
of the thing at his own disposal and it
is awesome because it's basically like
it's really like venom becomes God and
it's one of the coolest things right
because it's basically like Eddie Brock
essentially using this dream stone which
can grant him an unlimited amount of
power seemingly ur just been to his will
and then in turn like dawning this
insane amount of armor and then facing
off against like jack-o'-lantern who can
essentially do the same thing and then
defeating him but more so than that what
Eddie also does and this is kind of a
cool thing but he also does is that when
it comes to people he kind of looks at
him and says these people remind me of
where I was not enough so much in terms
of their physical weakness but in terms
of they so easily succumb to fear people
succumb to fear so incredibly fast and
what they need here is they need courage
they need hope they need the belief that
they can do something themselves and so
what is up happening is he uses the
dream stone and bonds a symbiote to all
these civilians who in turn start facing
off against the forces of Muspelheim and
win and so it's cool because he empowers
people to fight them fight for
themselves and then of course crates
like this giant axe thing and then like
has this huge amount of lightning that
it's like strikes jack-o'-lantern and
since we're crashing down of course she
loses the dream stone but like venom
summons summons like lightning I'm all
mostly climbed to title the video that
venom summons lightning just to see if
people would watch it but uh because
people be like what he can't do that
I have no idea that would be the case or
not regardless with jack-o'-lantern
taking out of course we end up learning
this guy is basically a coward now of
course following this thing's wrap up
pretty quickly the war which who is
watching the whole thing unfold and some
giant cauldron is like made fun of by
her by her teammates and then Eddie goes
back to the bunker of where he basically
spends time with Dylan now funny thing
they kind of also remember here Eddie
starts to talk about having the Venom
symbiote and one of the things that he
tells Dylan is that having the venom
having the Venom symbiote and then
losing it also loses the memories that
come with the venom Samiha right so all
the all the memories she has of of
hosting that symbiote of like carrying
it around
of like being venom a lot of those
memories are essentially going away now
we don't know that's a byproduct of the
dream stone or that's a byproduct of
just being away from the symbiote for
that long but it's but if I recall this
is a new thing this is not something
we've seen before there like somebody
becomes a host for the Venom symbiote
and they're imbued with all these
memories and experiences and everything
and they go through all these actions
and then once they lose it they lose all
the memories that go with it
the powers of course that's obvious but
in terms of these of the memories I've
never heard of that happening before so
it's kind of a cool little thing
but nonetheless this is a pretty sweet
little story of course there's no
there's kind of a follow up a bit of a
epilogue of sorts but it's pretty
awesome to see this whole thing unfold
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys at the sub button do
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]